today's new member of the day is James
sat SEC Sadek Sadek potassium may be a Z
or silent I really apologize James but
you are today's new member of the day
Mike Robinson that one I feel much more
confident with Mike Robinson is today's
long time sustaining member of the day
join them at w WJ pakman.com coupon
codes are available for those who want
them for those who need them
this is 20/20 will save you 40% off of
the membership of your choice let's go
to the phones at six one seven eight
three zero
4750 our first caller today is from the
905 area code caller from 905 who's
there what's on your mind today
[Music]
okay so how long is like we can barely
hear he sounds like you're underwater
but what's your name where are you
calling from
oh I'm from El Paso Texas okay what's
your name
um Kevin Kevin alright what's on your
mind Kevin I'm asking I'm a new I'll
follower of your show and I've been
watching been to watching the videos I
will question the 20/20 other chin sir
um right now bernie is leading in the
Democratic Party but hold on a second
where you've seen a poll that says
Bernie's in the lead the ones I see have
a Joe Biden in the lead even though he
hasn't declared yet which poll are you
looking oh well based on the ones who
have they're officially running yet he's
a number one right so he made 10 million
dollars of donations oh you're thinking
my nation is leading not in the polls
yes yes yes I'm sorry um do you think by
them or did the any table rigged against
Bernie Sanders this when I hadn't will
start running sir you're saying do I
think that if Joe Biden announces that
the DNC will rig it for Joe Biden yeah
kind of like bombing 2016 let's alert
Clinton I mean I'm worried about it I'm
worried about it yeah I I so there were
people a couple weeks ago who called in
and said that the DNC has already
decided Kamala Harris is
nominee and that they're going to work
to make her the nominee and at the time
I said you know it's possible I'm not
seeing evidence of that necessarily yet
and I actually think her campaign has
sort of been not doing so well since I
got that phone call Joe Biden as I
mentioned is already leading in polls
even though he hasn't announced and I
think that if anyone was going to cause
the DNC to say we are now going to get
involved in a partisan way it very well
could be Joe Biden who causes them to do
that sure okay so that's the only thing
that I'm worried about this election
because I don't think I'm Joe Biden can
be Donald Trump
hmm why not my just even though polls
say Donald Trump's approval rating is
low I think it's high and I think even
after the State of the Union speech I
went even higher so you just saw are you
saying you just don't believe what the
public approval polls say about like you
just think they're wrong numbers yeah
yeah
because I was at the Trump rally in
Oklahoma I wanted a better Ally to
perform against the rally and it was a
serious people know apostle is mostly
democratic on the whole Democrat mostly
yeah but that you can get in almost
anywhere in the US you can get sixty
five hundred people who support the
president to Tim to meet up listen I
think what you bringing up is
interesting I hope the DNC doesn't rig
it we're gonna be following it I
appreciate the call and I've got a bunch
of other people who want to get in here
so I'm gonna let you go